like no but if your girl cries
strategically and she's sitting there in
tears or just gently streaming down her
face
kind of a turn-on it's kind of a turn-on
but it goes what's going on here I got a
story for you I'm now on here I got a
story on that that's so funny I don't
know what it is about that when a girl
cries it gets a man it gets you a little
for some reason it gets you a little
horny cuz you want to comfort them and
then you're like well it brings you
close to them it's like I was at the bus
stop train station how long ago is this
training I don't know the cares but
let's say 15 years ago Kay let's say 30
I'm at the train station in Connecticut
and this dimepiece but like the kind of
girl with lip liner and who drives a
Fiero with [ __ ] hanging from them with
you know I mean a lady that works the
nightlife worked the night line lady of
the street covered in glitter smells
like perfume and just curves for all
[ __ ] today's Boulevard huh yeah what
juicy sweat you know the remember the
juicy sweatpants oh yeah yeah and and
and and just juicy in general just all
curves right and she's just got that
just frizzed out and the whole hair
everything is everything it's the kind
of girl yeah the kind of girl that's a
girl you're a girl when you're with your
girl she goes what is this lot how cheap
she looks so cheap and you're like I now
how cheap and you're like an i jack off
the exactly today
yeah I'd download the obvious stuff
hotter [ __ ] I get the rolodex I mean I
can see her nipples yeah like that that
situation so I'm looking at her and her
boyfriend who comes in who's built he's
just a big tank of a man just a big
burly son of a [ __ ] in sweatpants looks
like half a gangster and he's stand
there and she starts to cry because
she's leaving him she's leaving him he's
dropping her off and she's going back
home yes he's like um and he's like he
looks like he's a mad he's like hey
they're cuddling and stuff like that I
look down
he's got a [ __ ] really pumping
through his [ __ ] sweats it was so
inappropriate it's like
yeah well say something it's close to
all the life medals as he's kissing her
and then and then he's just he's trying
to keep his but his upper body forward
so you can't really you know suck him up
in his digs let them off no man she
couldn't do it there she couldn't do it
there I take it man and then he looked
at me and he goes hey I got a lot of
tension I need to relieve it I was like
wait can you I gotta catch my train bro
and he goes now you don't let seriously
bro bro ya help me out and he was big
and I was like we're in a train station
I don't even know are you yeah anyway
that's not your Connecticut role yeah my
Connecticut role yeah you can either get
what was interesting when you see my
back ripple and I pull myself up like a
champ like a champ thirty times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gif it's a gift
it's a gift